et la parole est à présent à jean
patrick courtois pour le groupe ump et
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais monsieur le
ministre en mon nom personnel et celle
c'est au nom de tous les membres de
cette assemblée rendre hommage aux
services de police il ya vos propres
services monsieur le ministre pour
l'arrestation rapide du abdel années
d'écart cette arrestation était permis
je tiens à le rappeler entre autres
grâce à l'utilisation du fichier fneg
créée par notre propre majorité
je tiens toutefois à dénoncer les propos
tenus par monsieur assouline assimilant
notre formation politique à cette
tragique fait divers les problèmes de
délinquance se multiplient en ville on
n'a de cesse de le répéter
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance renouvelle cet état de fait
l'explosion des crimes et délits se
poursuit et s'aggravent mois après mois
la plupart des indicateurs virent au
rouge
on constate ainsi une hausse de + 4 1 %
des atteintes aux biens et de + 3 % des
violences contre les personnes sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
par ailleurs la coupe des cambriolages
poursuit sa croissance de plus de 10% et
les vols enregistrent une évolution
similaire
sans parler des vols à la tire qui
augmente de plus de 14%
tout comme les actes de violence
sexuelle à plus de 8% les chiffres de la
délinquance ne cesse d'augmenter depuis
votre arrivée au pouvoir
à cela s'ajoutent les message d'impunité
délivré par madame le garde des sceaux
mais dans l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens s'ajoute également la
morosité des services de police et de
gendarmerie
ces services de sécurité intérieure se
sentent orphelins d'un ministre qui ne
leur donne pas les moyens suffisants par
suite des restrictions budgétaires pour
exercer aujourd'hui leurs missions
régaliennes
ils ont d'ailleurs exprimé un message de
ras-le-bol mercredi dernier cette
morosité de plus augmenté par décision
judiciaire qui en l'absence de
dispositions législatives précise on
encore rendu plus complexe les enquêtes
de police
mais la longe 110 millions d'euros que
vous venez d'annoncer semble peu par
rapport aux enjeux de sécurité
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
vous ne pouvez pas définir une politique
de sécurité à l'indépendance
d'arbitrages budgétaires imposées par
bercy relatif est variable
vous ne pouvez pas calmé la morosité des
services à coude rallonge financière
sans un cap clair pour leur avenir
c'est donc d'une politique stricte
hurel de nous avons besoin qui passera
notamment par un gros déploiement des
forces de police et de gendarmerie sur
l'ensemble du territoire et notamment en
zone rurale où le diagon 6 12
je citerai l'exemple de la saône et
loire car la délinquance de proximité
est en hausse de plus de 20% en un an
cette augmentation à multiples facteurs
dont la recrudescence des cambriolages
et la mobilité des dunks ans que l'on
constate plus d'aidé dans les
territoires rivaux il en est ainsi du
vol de cuivre d'installation électrique
public et du vol de fonte par des
groupes d'individus parfaitement
organisés en filière itinérante la
question monsieur ministre est donc de
savoir quand allez vous définir une
politique de sécurité durable ambitieuse
pour notre pays et sécurisant pour nos
services de police et de gendarmerie
merci monsieur le président il vous
reste un peu de temps pour réagir aux
propos du ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur courtois
votre préoccupation au sujet des moyens
des forces de l'ordre ou sonores vous
avez raison sur l'objectif je regrette
d'ailleurs le le ton polémique que sur
les moyens humains
treize mille 700 postes ont été
supprimés entre 2007 et 2012 et nous non
d'arrêter cette hémorragie
nous remplaçons tous les départs à la
retraite et nous créons tous les ans 400
à 500 postes de policiers de gendarmes
donc j'ai l'impression vous adressiez
pas moi mais vous adressiez à quelqu'un
d'autre en tout cas à l'un de mes
prédécesseurs sur le sneg vous avez
raison il a été créé et je me permets de
vous le rappeler en 1999 par elisabeth
guigou pour les délinquants sexuels et
les crimes très graves il a été amplifié
par nicolas sarkozy mais arrêtons ce
genre de polémique et je vous connais
trop pour que vous puissiez avoir un peu
de hauteur sur ces questions là c'est
une continuité les questions de sécurité
sont trop grave pour qu'on les aborde
surtout ici au sénat dans la polémique
et puis enfin vous avez raison sur un
sujet suffit pas de moyens il faut des
moyens humains
il faut aussi investir et pour la
première fois alors que ces cinq
dernières années les budgets
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
avaient diminué
ils sont stables ils augmentent ils
augmentent et j'ai même obtenu le dégel
de des crédits qui avaient été gelés au
début d'année pour la gendarmerie la
police parce qu'il faut des véhicules
évidemment du carburant pour les faire
fonctionner et puis vous avez également
raison
parce qu'il faut un redéploiement sur le
terrain et il faut et c'est aussi
l'objet de l'outil statistique pour que
police et gendarmes s'attaque aux vraies
causes et aux vrais phénomènes de
délinquance les violences sur les
personnes les violences faites aux
femmes
les cambriolages les crimes bien sûr et
les trafics de drogue et d'armes qui
sont aujourd'hui au coeur d'un certain
nombre de cités mais également qu'ils
atteignent les zones les territoires les
départements euros c'est cet ensemble
cette politique qui passe aussi par deux
des redéploiement police gendarmerie
comme nous l'avons fait les zones de
sécurité prioritaire c'est cette
politique d'ensemble qui nous permettra
d'être efficace et de répondre à cette
attente des français avec le souci de
l'intérêt général du rassemblement et
jamais de la polémique
merci mr